welcome back to CBS mornings here's a
look at conditions right now in Daytona
Beach on Florida's Northeast Coast
there's already been some serious
flooding there and in we'll continue to
hit that area on its way to the Atlantic
Ocean Daytona Beach mayor Derrick Henry
joins us right now how are you doing
good morning Derek
good morning
mayor what are the conditions like in
Daytona Beach right now
well they that we've had sustained uh
winds
starting at about nine last night and
they have been
powerful for this long and the rain has
been
sustained as well we've we've never
really experienced this length with much
more to come so we are uh concerned uh
greatly to say the least
so Mr Mayor I know you're still
assessing the damage but what are your
top priorities right now as you speak
with us
well the top priorities are always on
human safety you know we have people who
will and are uh in areas that are
impassable uh and obviously they're
without major life Necessities so uh
it's it's human lives that's the first
priority and then you begin to assess uh
the damage that is taken on your
buildings and infrastructure
well mayor on the on the subject of
human lives uh taking first priority
there's a report online from one of the
local stations there that a seven the
two-year-old man uh was found in York
County uh and maybe the first confirmed
Death In This Storm can you confirm that
is that true
I cannot confirm that because it was not
uh in my municipality uh and I haven't
received a report on that
you've lived in Daytona Beach your
entire life so you know this city very
well how does this compare to what
you've seen and dealt with in the past
we know Florida is often hit with
hurricanes but this one is different
East storm is is unique uh this one
however the the duration and the breadth
and width of it is unique in my lifetime
thus far uh in in terms of our
anticipation of the amount of rain
um so you know like I say each storm is
unique but this one is is quite fearful
and uh since 2004 we certainly haven't
experienced anything with this magnitude
when we had the three storms uh back to
back
you know mayor two populations that
we've been thinking about a lot this
morning are the the senior population in
the state of Florida I know there are a
lot of seniors there in Daytona Beach as
well as there are in every city in
Florida and also newcomers a lot of
people during the pandemic move to
Florida there are tens of thousands of
new residents who've not seen anything
like this before uh what are your
thoughts on those two populations this
morning
well you tried to educate as many of the
newcomers as you could and then you
tried to do things to support the
seniors with things like sandbags well
relocation we have a great coordinated
system throughout our region to help
folks uh moving into shelters uh so you
you work and do all that you can in
advance and once the storm is uh present
you then uh respond and react as quickly
as you can and we've got great a team of
First Responders who are you know
prepared to do what they can to rescue
and and make things as palatable as
possible moving forward
well Mary you know you've heard of that
Waffle House Index it's all anecdotal of
course people say if the Waffle House
closes and you know this was a really
bad storm right did The Waffle House
close in your in your town yes indeed
Waffle House is shut down
all right all right we thank you so much
for your time I know you've got a lot to
do and you got a busy day we thank you
for taking your time with us this
morning thank you mayor